Hey, David does a lot of discussion about
taxes, wealth tax, capital gains, tax income
tax question.
Can you just tell us what you think the top
marginal tax rates should be?
Yes, I can.
I think it should be between 70 and 73%.
Um, now I am not suggesting that at a $500,000
a year in income where the question that I
have is at what income level should a 70%
marginal tax rate kick in?
It shouldn't be after you earn $50,000.
I don't believe it should be after you earn
$150,000 I don't believe it should be.
Once you're earning $500,000, I think that
we should get to 70 or 73%.
The overwhelming majority of the research
I've seen shows that if scaled correctly,
topping out at 70 or 73 generates the most
government revenue before you start losing
revenue because the tax is so high that people
start getting disincentivized from work.
So I've seen proposals that kick in the 70%
at $1 million a year of income.
I've seen proposals that do it at $2 million
a year of income or $5 million a year of income
or $10 million a year of income, maybe 10
millions too high.
That really is a very small percentage of
the population, but there are two things to
keep in mind.
One, uh, it's the marginal tax rate below
that level of income, wherever you set it,
you are paying a lower rate.
And number two, there should be more rates
between our current top rate.
I believe the current top rate is 37% there
needs to be more between 37 and 70 if that
were to be kicked in, so it would be graduated,
you might go, okay, I think right now for
20 or four 80 maybe is where 37% kicks in.
Then you might go to 45 between four 80 and
seven 50 or a million.
Then you might go to 52 between 1,000,002
million.
It's got a scale and those are the models
that generate the most government revenue
and they are not so oppressive that they start
to disincentivize work.
In a, that will be problematic for the economy.
A lot of research on this, I'm always up to
having my mind changed on it.
Now there's other questions that are ancillary
to this that are important ones.
Like for example, should capital gains be
taxed at that same rate?
Right now there's a lot of very wealthy people
who uh, if they were to pay income tax as
a, as earned income as wages would be paying
37%, but because they are receiving a lot
of this income through capital gains, whether
it's dividends or other sorts of capital gains,
selling stocks that they've made money on,
um, they are taxed at the lower capital gains
rates.
So one idea that is often mentioned is in
order to eliminate that, you really need to
raise the capital gains rate to simply be
what the, uh, earned income, the, the wage
rate would be personal income tax rates, so
that there is no advantage to earning the
income via capital gains rather than working
for a living as, as some like to say I'm open,
I'm open to raising, I believe capital gains
should be raised, but I think you also need
more levels previously or right now I believe
that there's just two rates for capital gains.
I think it should be progressive.
It needs to have more tiers than two.
And I'm getting, I'm going from memory here,
I'm, I'm just riffing.
Um, but I do think that there are more delicate
considerations when you raise capital gains.
I think it should be done, but I think we
need to understand that it is not the same
as raising taxes on a wages.
But to go back to the beginning, I believe
the top marginal tax rates should be 70%.
The debate is at what level of income should
that rate kick in.
And I want to hear from you, uh, on this issue.
We've got a fantastic bonus show coming up
for you today.
What is the bonus show?
Well, everyday we do an hour show.
That show is available to everybody.
It goes out on the radio, it goes out on TV,
it's the free podcast.
It gets chopped up and uploaded to YouTube
as video clips.
But there was another show that we do every
day.
It's called the bonus show.
And you can get access to it two ways.
You can become a member@joinpacman.com it's
very cheap.
It supports the work we do and you get instant
access to the bonus show.
Or you can go to patrion.com/david Pakman
show, uh, and make a pledge of at least $5
a month from $5 and up.
You get access to the bonus show and then
you will be able to join us as a producer
Pat.
We'll also be doing on the bonus show, Pat
now also hosting the Friday bonus.
Show himself,
much to the pleasure and dismay of different
people in the audience.
Pat will talk to you very, very short.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.